that's in the braves sunny skies it's
gorgeous 77
degrees and not the easiest
to face max scherzer on a sunny
afternoon max 10 and 8 career against
atlanta
going for career win number 175 today
has been slider susceptible in this
series let's see if he can time one here
again an 02 pitch
and it's poked into right center field
that's going to get down and the braves
are going to take the lead a two out two
strike hit
this one from darneau who slides in
safely at second two two strike hits off
max scherzer and the braves strike first
in the first how about that gets him out
front but he's able to split the gap
adam duvall and austin reilly the next
two for atlanta duval fourth in the
league in homers
strikeout number three all in similar
fashion two down here's austin reilly
nasty change up diving
four case for scherzer a quick second
inning yeah he was smelling a one two
three drupal cabrera will lead off for
the nationals the first baseman first
pitch second inning c
you
later as jubal cabrera
sixth of the year
and then that's on one swing back even
there goes the no-hitter there goes the
shutout and now we dance
we're just one hitter off we got the
percussion section over there
and we're dancing i like it
[Applause]
i know a good lead at second tie game
the pitch
is lined into center field that's down
for a base hit marcakus comes through
darnold will score
nick is on his way to second and he'll
stand with you guessed it another double
two more hits for atlanta in the fourth
inning it's a 2-1 game center cut and
the way they were shading nick to left
center good hustle able to get a double
and an rbi kurt suzuki bouncing ball to
second first time up freddie freeman's
playing second
on contact soto coming home
safe
ozzie albee's threw it in
and juan beat it the game is tied what a
great jump by one soda albie's had to go
to his left a couple of steps and that
was the difference
look at the slide by juan soto away from
the base left hand the oven mitt
reaching back and then that's tied at
two
now two on one out
and carter key boom the hitter
that one is little pop freddy freeman
back pedals drops the ball
throw to second they'll get a force
throw to third and the tag in time how
about that double play
everybody had to freeze because it
looked like a sure out
freddie freeman dropped the ball through
to second to fourth tame the thames and
kurt suzuki in no man's land was thrown
out at third they could have called that
an infield flying the batter would
automatically be out if so the runners
advance on their own risk but when the
ball dropped it's in play and it is an
unconventional double play to send us to
the fifth inning
now the league's leading hitter and he's
going to hit a double play ball right to
the bag
and then the ball goes off freddie
freeman's glove into the dugout
and the nats will score two runs on that
ground ball
wow garcia and robles both scoring it's
a sloppy baseball i mean you can't ask
for an easier double play and albies
throws it away
freddy freeman's there to catch it and
then he misses it jurors are back out
there after 104 pitches see if they can
get him out of this game and swanson
will launch
deep left
soto he's got it up against the wall
what a catch i mean talk about how juan
soto plays in front of the visiting
bullpen so he had to go a long way for
this and then he jumps at the right time
and he shows you that he caught it what
a play by juan soto actors are digging
it and the braves will again bring the
tying around to the plate
[Applause]
fly ball well hit center robles going
back he's gonna turn it is gone another
home run for adam duvall this one ties
the game at four here's ozzy
swaying and another fly ball wallops
center again this one might go it does
go
two more two run homers for atlanta the
braves are back in front
wow four runs like that in about 10
pitches another fastball that just
leaked back over the plate dave martinez
of course sends his stud back out there
and now he's done the nationals will now
walk freddie freeman intentionally
and face marcelo zuna
that is smoked into left center field of
base hit late start for ozzy but he's
gonna streak around third he's gonna
come home ozuna provides the braves with
a big insurance run it is seven to four
freeman at third ozuna at first
that one tapped off the plate pork's got
it second base high throw and the out at
second in any event freddy freeman comes
home to score another nice insurance run
to get to 8-4 pitch number 13 for martin
in the inning here it comes
and it is a strikeout braves have won
the series 8-4 is your final score